good morning John today is a day that
will live in infamy not actually I just
wanted to use that filter so this video
comes to you in three parts the first
part is that the vlogbrothers are
participating and all you have to do is
go to rhettandlink.com/store note and
join the vlogbrothers team and then
upload a video of yourself as a response
to this video of you doing your
supernote the male and female vlog
brother members who have the longest
supernote will receive the right if they
so wish to introduce a vlogbrothers
video by saying good morning Hank or
good morning John depending on who they
want to be talking to all you have to do
is have the lung capacity of a fully
grown blue whale but if you don't have
the lung capacity of the largest animal
to ever have lived on our planet you can
still participate because there is also
a prize for the cumulative tames
supernote effort and so if all of
nerdfighteria gets together in super
notes that means another response to
this video and guess what we become the
super new champions of the world so
please go to rhettandlink.com/store note
and leave your super note video
responses below the second part is a
very special birthday wish it's Charlie
McDonald's birthday today charlie is so
cool like if you haven't already
subscribed to him I don't believe you so
Alex today said that we should write
ukulele songs for him so I did
[Music]
he's so rock'n'roll and I even like you
smoking it happy birthday now the third
thing I want to talk about today is this
science of supernote there are two
things at play here there's your lung
capacity and there's your ability to
hold your breath because while you are
exhaling you may have noticed you are
not inhaling and inhaling is the thing
that keeps you from being a dead person
and so your body wants very much for you
to consistently inhale because your body
turns out really likes being alive so
what you need is to expand your lung
capacity decrease the rate of air
leaving your lungs and increase the
amount of time that you can hold your
breath now number one to expand your
lung capacity you should be standing up
I failed at that you should take deep
breaths blow them all the way out and
then take deep breaths and try and feel
what it feels like to have your lungs
all the way full second you have to
decrease the rate at which air is
leaving your lungs now one way to do
this is to go ahh but that is illegal no
growling super notes this year so yes
you must be talking but don't do it too
loud and try and control the amount of
air that's leaving your throat ah it's a
lot less air then ah lastly you want to
increase the amount of time that you can
hold your breath there are two
components of this psychological and
physiological psychologically you have
to recognize that your body is telling
you to breathe and you shouldn't do it
so just don't because you'll be fine
physiological what you do want to do is
super oxygenate your blood which
requires you to fill and blow out and
fill and blow out your lungs very
rapidly and in quick succession and
you'll start to feel your gums tingle
I'm not kidding
when your gums start tingling that's the
time to do your supernote boom and that
is all also they found a planet that may
have liquid water on it 20 light years
away that could easily support life
very exciting John I'll see you on
Monday
you